Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man,
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting? What?
No. Sadaqa. Brothers and sisters, I era
is getting thousands of Shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training Dawah. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that Sadaqa Jariyah
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam in
sha Allah by donating whatever money in
sha Allah and support I era right now in
sha Allah. Enjoy the video.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. So, this is a video of
three Israeli Zionists. One is a mayor,
the other is a settlement leader who is
known
to be
is trying to get set established
settlements in Kiryat Shmona, which is
in northern Israel near the Lebanon
border where
a lot of Shia Muslims lived that they
expelled and killed. Israeli settlement
leader Erez Saranga Saranga
of Margaliot breaks down in tears. So,
this is the group. They are obviously
stealing lands and they are upset that
the lands that they stole and the house
that they stole are on the fire by the
Iranians or Hezbollah for that for that
matter.
So, again, so that's one that we're
going to watch the video and it's going
to be very very satisfying for you guys.
Let's go straight to that video and then
watch the mayor break down and cry like
a little child. And why are they crying?
Let's find out who these people really
are. LET'S WATCH FOR OURSELVES.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN CALL MY CHANNEL
HOLDING POLE.
I'M GOING TO END UP WITH MEDINA
WITH ME AND I'LL SEE YOU AT THE MEDINA.
I HAVE CHARLOTTE COME OUT TO ME.
>> INTERESTING. I MEAN
>> [sighs]
>> WHEN YOU SEE THAT, YOU KNOW, one really
if they didn't understand the context,
your heart will be broken.
But then when you realize that this is
the same individual who let's read for
ourselves before we go to the other
mayor screaming his lungs out as well
like a chicken. Who is he? So his his
Moshav was built on the ruins of the
Shia village of Hunin. He was repeatedly
He he has repeated He has repeatedly
called for ethnic cleansing of the
southern Lebanon in the past 2 and 1/2
years. So this is him breaking down. So
he's the one who is robbed the people
from their houses. Yes, the Shia Muslims
who are living in Lebanon. Yes. Once
ethnically cleansed the Gaza and the
Palestinians. And now for some I just
don't understand the psychology.
You've done the same to others and
you're like, "No, you have to shut up
and we're going to we're going to
ethnically cleanse we want to cleanse
you. We want to wipe you. Genocide."
But when a rocket is sent towards their
place, whatever it is for that matter.
And again, I've made it very clear. I
condemn the killing of any innocent
people, be they Israelis, Zionists,
Muslim, Shia, you name it. We condemn.
We're consistent, morally consistent,
not strategically. Now let's watch the
other video of this mayor. Let's see
what the contention this mayor had. Yes?
Okay, let's see what he had to say.
Because it just gets more interesting.
These people are just weird narcissists.
If you start a new war in the state of
Israel,
What do you want to TELL ME NOW?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN? YOU KNOW WHY?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I THINK I GOT TO GET SOME MORE OF THOSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN? YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YOU KNOW WHY? YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY?
>> [music]
>> YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY? YOU KNOW WHY?
>> AND WHAT CAN I SAY? I'M
ABSOLUTELY
AMAZED. I'm
I'm lost for words.
The the the the the complaint he has is
basically in a nutshell not that they
were hit. And then again, I I said it
very clearly. I I condemn like I don't
want anyone to be in that situation.
That situation is talking about about
innocent children by look these kids who
are being propagandized and brainwashed.
And then you have the adults who are
systematically and unilaterally
want to ethnic cleansing of the
Palestinians and they mock and laugh at
them. Even then, yes, I'm I'm not
talking about the fighting individuals
fighting. If they're fighting
soldiers etc. man or woman without just
say sorry you're you're you're you're a
soldier. I'm talking about innocent
people that even want the cleansing of
the Palestinian people. I don't want any
of those innocent children Zionist young
children who have been brainwashed to
hate them.
I wouldn't want any I wouldn't want this
on anyone. What amazes me is that they
have been doing this systematically for
over nearly a
century.
And they are upset. This man is upset
this mayor who's who's
you can't make this up. They've one of
stolen lands there on the border of in
Lebanon. And they are upset because they
cannot get to a shelter fast enough or
that when they're in a shelter like what
they're supposed to do with their
children 24 hours.
Am I missing something? I'm just trying
to understand.
They are they think Do you really think
you're going to live in peace? Do you
really think the God that you worship is
going to let you like like like the God
that you worship like I'll be honest
with you that you believe you're a
chosen people. Without respect you got
this is racism. This is this is this is
like
superiority. And you're basically saying
we are God's chosen people. Do you
really think a God that's
objectively a just God
is going to let you live in peace
knowing what you've done to the
Palestinians? Like do you really believe
you're going to go and steal someone's
land? Just imagine for a second I steal
someone's land. The family members come
and I have massacred them and I've
killed them and the family members come
to take my life. Yes, my life. They're
coming for me, not for my family, for
me. And I'm like, you know,
how could you know, you know, help me go
to a shelter quicker?
You can't make this up. You genuinely
Guys, you can't make this up. You know,
do you think that's why when Allah says,
do you really think Allah is unaware of
what they're doing?
He only delays them for a day that I can
look in horror, but don't forget there's
going to be consequences in this life.
Do you think you're going to live in
peace? I mean, imagine me living in a
land I stole
and constantly being attacked from like
the UN tries to make it very clear, they
have a right to defend yourself. Okay,
armed resistance.
How could you live in peace when you've
done the greatest calamity and atrocity
and stolen lands because you think
you're a God's chosen person
people? Yeah?
How are you going to live in peace in
those lands? You're never Allah will
never make you live in peace knowing the
amount of people, the Christians and the
Muslims and the Jews that you've
oppressed in those lands as well, by the
way. Yeah, you Zionists. Don't confuse
them with the Jews.
We want those lands to return back to
the Palestinians where the Christians,
Jews, and the Muslims live together and
when Muslims protect the Jews against
anti-Semitism from the Christians. Not
all Christians I'm saying. So, and this
is just lastly, we'll just end off this
with this
individual who's crying on the floor,
grown man crying on the floor. Look at
this guy.
I mean, at least have some honor, man.
The hell was that? You know, grown man.
Oh my god.
The hell's wrong with you, but at least
you
you're going to die like at least have
some honor and dignity. What is wrong
with you? Crying at least you know, like
like this is unbelievable. Like I said
to you before, guys, my issue here is
not
like I said before, I condemn any kind
of innocent people from all sides. I
don't care if it whatever it is who is
killing innocent people, I condemn. I
don't care who they are.
Okay, but the key here is that they've
been doing this to so many people and so
far now when war this is the
consequences of war that you've been
propagating and pushing out there. What
can I say? So, may Allah deal with those
people and protect I'll say again the
innocents in Israel, the innocent
Zionists
Zionist innocents who have been
brainwashed. Okay. Who have been
brainwashed, these innocent children,
kids, etc.
Women who have been maybe brainwashed or
even some men, whatever. Yeah. May Allah
protect them. The rest who are calling
for ethnic genocide etc. May God deal
with you guys. Yes, may God deal with
you guys. That's all I'm going to say.
Brothers and sisters, assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh.